Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob and we are picking back up again with dark Knights metal,
but this one gets a little crazy. And so I think that before we kick this off,
what we need to do is have a discussion about the overboard. Now, in reality,
it would probably be who've us since we are comics explained,
it would probably behoove us to essentially take everything that's happened with
regards to dark nights metal, and these,
these additions and creations in relation to like how the multi-verse works and
all that kind of stuff to kind of consolidate all of that into a singular video
and then makes sense of everything that's happened.
But for what we're going to do in this video,
we're going to have a conversation about the overboard, right?
Because the overboard plays a role in all of this actually plays a huge role in
all of this. So the way it works in DC comics, right?
Leaving out like the dark multiverse and all that kind of stuff.
The way this works in DC comics is that you have like a singular universe and DC
uses numerical designations for their universes. But unlike Marvel,
whereas arbitrarily established DC doesn't order, right? So you have earth zero,
then you have earth one, then you have earth two, you have earth three, right?
It's kind of how their whole thing goes and works forward.
From there something like zero or earth prime,
that's where you read most of these DC comics ever since the new 52.
Now outside of these individual universes,
you have of course the multi-verse and you guys know this stuff,
but you guys have the multi-verse a collection of universes.
The presence is basically the one who created the multi-verse right.
That's kind of been established over the years in different countries crisis on
infinite earths, the subsequent stories that we've seen, like doomsday,
which referenced a crisis on infinite earths and solidified the creation of the
multi-verse by the hand of the presence in the DC rebirth landscape whites,
we know it's still in continuity,
but the big question to ask here is if the presence created the multi-verse who
created the presence. So that's where the omnivorous comes into play.
And we've talked about this, a Marvel colleagues, right?
Did the omniverse is basically all the multi verses that exist.
So at the multi-verse from Marvel comics and the multi-verse from like spawn and
like the, like, if it, if it exists out there in reality,
it's part of the Omni verse, right?
It's just the omniverse encompasses everything that currently exists that we are
currently aware of. Right? So our universe and assuming that we,
as human beings here in the real world are part of a multi-verse and includes
our multi-verse as well.
And so the over void was kind of like this introduction by grant Morrison that
was designed to take the place of just saying like all people in creation right
now by and large grant Morrison did it in relation to DC comics.
But if you look at the nature of grant Morrison,
it kind of expands beyond DC comics. And so what we kind of do is we can,
we can look at like the real world here. And we can say, like,
in the 1930s you had like Malcolm Wheeler Nicholson,
and you had Harry Donenfeld and you had an X games and you had Robert Kantor and
you had Gardner Fox. And these were the people who basically created DC comics,
as we know it today. And then in the 1930s,
you also had like Jack Kirby and you had Joe Simon.
They were the ones who created people like captain America.
And that over the years,
different writers have contributed to characters in different ways, right?
Bob Kane, bill finger created Batman.
It was just kind of the way these things work.
And so when grant Morrison created over void in, in final crisis,
instead of saying like once upon a time there was Gardner Fox and Maxine and
Robert Canterbury and Harry Donenfeld and Malcolm William Nicholson,
and Gardner Fox and Stan Lee, Jack Hurdy, and Joe Simon,
instead of like running off all these names, he was just like, in the beginning,
there was the overboard. And that's why you basically have this kind of, this,
this depiction in the sense that the over void did not initially become aware of
the fact that the DC multi-verse existed.
Because if you apply this kind of meta textual concept to it,
it was basically grant Morrison saying before these guys created DC comics and
Marvel comics, they had lives, they had wives and they had kids and they had,
you know,
friends and family and they were going to school and all that kind of stuff.
Right.
And it wasn't until later on in their life that they decided to start creating
comic books. And that's when they became aware of the existence of things.
Right? So it's super meta textual,
and it can be difficult to wrap your head around, but there's no,
there's no denying that. Like, it can be difficult to wrap your head around,
but that's kind of how all this, this whole over void thing works.
And so the idea and the reason why this matters is because as we get into this,
of course, we've had, Metron, who's been dead for quite some time in DC comics,
right? He's been dead for a while.
I think ever since the events of dark side war,
but with the Batman who laughs basically achieving the full totality of Dr.
Manhattan's powers and becoming this just crazy powerful multi-vessel source of
energy.
The first thing he does is challenged Perpetua because Perpetua seems to more or
less be equal to himself in power.
And these two beings are fighting quite literally for the fate of the
multi-verse. If you guys are a little confused, you know,
a little ConFuzzled in terms of like the,
the level of power we're talking about here to put this into context,
this was like when the specter and the ante monitor fought during crisis on
infinite earths, right?
It was their fight that destroyed what was left of the multi-verse, right.
It was just them fighting that laid waste to basically everything.
But you're basically talking about two insanely powerful beings here.
The reason why this matters is because while all this has been happening,
spinning dark nights, metal, and the, and, and you know,
the Batman who laughs gaining all this power. And so and so forth,
the over void has been watching. And the over void is actually curious.
And so what the Overwatch does is it basically sends an Emissary into the main
DC universe right into, into this particular place right here.
I guess we can kind of call it the multi-verse if we want to.
But basically this being shows up here, it's kind of a chronicler of sorts.
And it's curious, right? It's curious, what's going on here.
And so what it ends up doing is basically teleporting to the hellscape right?
Which is premise previously Femiscura and it comes across the joker,
the first person at meets. And it's like, are you the one who drew me here?
Right? Are you the one whose presence drew me to this place?
And then he immediately kind of picks up and says, no, you're just the joker,
right? Like if anything, you're a nuisance on your earth. But aside from that,
you're wildly insignificant, right?
You don't really matter in the greater scheme of things.
And then he basically ends up moving to the next cell.
And that's when he comes across Roger Hayden, the psychopath.
And the reason why he grabs a psycho pirate is because remember where you've had
events crisis on infinite earth and zero hour crisis and time and infinite
crisis and final crisis.
One of the things that we've kind of reiterated here is that crisis on infinite
earths destroyed the multi-verse infinite crisis,
brought the multi-verse back and final crisis made the heroes aware of it.
But after each one of these major crisis events,
you usually see some kind of reboot, right?
In the sense that the heroes didn't remember anything that was going on before
those crisis events were really before crisis on infinite earths,
infinite crisis and final crisis.
Weren't really as grandiose in scale as the original crisis of it.
That's why I say DC's only ever rebooted twice the original crisis event and the
new 52 by, but even when we go into new 52,
most people don't remember anything before the new 52.
It's why Barry Allen initially forgot who Wally West was. It's why,
when you had pre new 52 Superman who showed up in the new 52 universe,
people didn't initially know who he was.
And then you had the whole Superman reborn story arc where basically him and the
new 52 version merged.
And then you got like the original Superman as we know him. Right.
That kind of a thing. It was kind of a wonky story,
but the long and short of this is that cycle pirate does remember all of that.
But psycho pirate remembers life remembers how things work before the events of
crisis on infinite ERs. And he remembers how things were after that.
And he remembers everything before the events of flashpoint and he knows
everything that's been going on since. Right?
So he's the only true source of knowledge in so far as the entire timeline
before, during and after the crises that DCS had.
And so one of the things this guy basically says here is that he's,
he's known as chronicler, right? That's basically his name, right?
His name is chronicler. And that he has what's called the codex Omni versa.
And that he is a person that sent into a universe to Chronicle the universe
document. Why it is that it's dying and then leave. And that's basically,
it that's his whole purpose. He's more or less just like a librarian,
a chronicler. And so as he goes through here, and as he looks into the mind of,
of psycho pirate, he basically recalls everything, right?
Like the original justice society of America before the events of prices on
offenders, the heroes as they existed after,
and then everything that came after the event of flashpoint. Right. New 52.
And so when he's looking at that,
like it immediately strikes him as interesting because he's kind of like this
multi versus remarkable, right? It's not like most multi verses that I've seen,
that have been destroyed where there aren't really any superheroes there. Right.
Where it's basically just kind of mundane. This is a little strange to me.
And so from there, like it kind of piques his interest, you know? And he's like,
let's see what else is here.
The funny thing about it is that when he explains himself and says, like,
I'm always sent into a multi-verse when the Moseley versus about to die a kind
of strike cycle pilot, like, wait a minute, like this is the end, right.
This is how it ends. The funny thing about this too,
is psycho pirate tries to use as a Medusa mask on chronicler. It doesn't work.
Right. And we'll,
we'll find out more about why it doesn't work here in a minute. I mean,
he kind of offers an explanation and saying that he's incapable of feeling for
the dead.
And so basically it's kind of him saying like this multi-verse is going to die.
And so, because you're a dead man, I don't really feel anything for you,
but the reason why the Medusa mask doesn't work is actually a little deeper than
that, right? We're not really deeper, but it's a little different than that.
And so from there,
he ends up teleporting to another location and is immediately met by like all
these different robots, right? These, these kinds of, you know,
drones and somewhat any wipes them out with a wave of his hand.
And they're all totally destroyed,
which proves to be a big deal because these are the forces of real docks, right?
The son of brainiac.
So you're talking about the son of like a 12th level intelligence who created
these drones. That would be a challenge for someone like Superman, right?
Let alone an army of them. And so this guy's power is pretty high up there,
but as he starts talking to rural docs, but when you think about this,
is it real doc says he's been sending signals into the greater omniverse to
basically find a way to escape this multi-verse before its inevitable death.
Right? So Brotox knows the multi-verse is going to die right here.
Like he knows this is, this is going to happen, but everything is going to end.
And that's why I say dark nights, metal is in effect a crisis event.
It's leading to the death of the multi-verse.
And that's usually what a crisis means.
It means like they're going to reboot or something along those lines. Right.
It's kind of become part and parcel with DC nomenclature ever since the original
crisis event. Right. It's just kind of what it means. Now.
The funny thing about this is that rural docs had registered and incursion from
the omniverse basically, meaning like he registered this guy arriving, right.
You know, chronicler arriving from the AMI verse.
And that's why he kind of knew it was only a matter of time before the
chronicler came here. And so what he does is actually pitch them a deal.
And he says, here's what I'll do.
If you take me out of this multi-verse and take me to a better multi-verse,
it'll actually survive that I will give you all the recorded history.
That's inside the databanks that belonged to my father brainiac, right?
Every world he ever recorded across all of his existence across the multi-verse
right here. I'll give you all that stuff. And so the responsible chronicler is,
well, I mean, I do appreciate you giving me all that,
but I'm not authorized to make deals with dead men basically saying I'm not
going to take you to a new multi-verse. And instead,
what he actually ends up doing is basically absorbing that knowledge from rural
docs and then looking around, right?
Because rural docs offers them an explanation on like everything outside of
earth. The psycho pirate never really functioned outside of earth. Right.
He was never part of the green lantern Corps or part of like the new gods or
anything along those lines.
And so you actually end up having him end up having rural docs,
offering that kind of explanation, right. Showing him that information.
And the crazy thing is chronically, it looks at this and says,
there's so much power in this universe. How could you let it get to this point?
Like, how could you let your,
your multi-verse get to this point where it's on the verge of collapse,
that it doesn't make any sense, right?
You have enough power to overthrow virtually any threat you face.
How could you let it get to this point?
Now we're real docs initially tries to take over, um, take over the,
the chronicler and then says like,
I intend to use your power to leave this place, the Chronicles responses.
Do you really want to see what lies beyond your reality?
Do you only want to see the sorts of multi verses I've recorded as they've died?
And that's when he shows him the con uh, Dakota ex Omni versa.
Now we don't necessarily see what's in the codex Omni versa,
but we're given an explanation of what is in there and what the chronic or
basically tells us is that like among the various multi verses that he's seen,
this one is the only one that really has the kind of power that's being
displayed here that within this multi-verse that exists here,
that this one's unique. Now, if I'm also a betting man,
assuming the chronicler has visited, like the Marvel multi-verse,
it's kind of DC comics basically saying are multi versus better.
Right. That's kind of what it is. That's kind of what they're saying here.
But the overall point is that there is nothing else out there, right?
And this kind of comes by way of the response of real docs when the chronic or
leaps, right. When the chronic was like, I require more knowledge,
your knowledge is far too limited, right?
I require a better understanding of this whole universe that's out there.
And we basically ends up taking off. But the response of real docs is no,
there has to be something better out there, right?
There has to be something better than this place.
But the response of the chronicler is no,
you didn't cherish what you have or your multi-verse is coming to an end.
And it sucks because your multi-verse was so special. And so like, so it's,
it's kind of like if I took you to a different multi-verse,
it wouldn't be nearly as good as this one. And in fact it would probably suck.
It would be worse, right? So I'd be taking you to a worse place,
which is not going to happen.
And so what he ends up doing is traveling to the moon, right?
Teleporting to the moon in the midst of this massive thing, right.
Between Perpetua and the Batman who laughs right.
The document Hatton who lasts kind of character, right.
He actually ends up picking up the skull of Metro and then basically says like,
I need clarity from one who has seen this universe is I'm seeing it now and
observer. So basically if he wants to better understand this universe,
as it exists in the moment and Metron is the only one who can do that, right?
He's the only one who surveyed the entirety of the universe and gathered as much
information as he possibly can. It's the nature of Metro, right?
It's what he does.
And so what he does here is basically resurrect this guy from the dead.
And so what this gives us is this indication that chronicler is an almost
omnipotent character. This guy is huge in terms of power.
The other part of this is we get some massive explanations and exposition in so
far as how all this kind of hierarchy stands, right. The presence,
all that kind of stuff. And so when Medtronic wakes up,
it's basically like he's been dead all this time. Right.
So he doesn't really know anything about, uh, about dark nights, metal,
the Batman who laughs any of that stuff, he's been dead this whole time.
And so it was kind of like when chronicler kind of explains it all to him,
he's just sort of like, wow, okay.
So Perpetua apparently was locked in the source wall.
She was the creator of this multi-verse as it exists, that's kind of crazy.
Right. She was defeated. She was locked inside the source wall.
The whole multi-verse was recreated by her sons. Right.
And then she manipulated the auntie monitor into becoming the villain that he
was, which led to the second crisis. Right. So crisis on infinite earths. Right.
It led to that event.
And then she's kind of just been manipulating things ever since.
So she could eventually escape the source wall and then you serve control of the
multi-verse. Right. So, it's kind of crazy.
And then the Batman who laughs is a version of Batman from the dark multi-verse
and then he ended up getting the power of Dr.
Manhattan who came here from a different universe. And then it's, it's just,
it's it's he basically gets the full explanation of everything that's been going
on here. And the idea is that as he talks to the chronicler,
the chronicler is saying things like,
I wish to understand why things are the way they are.
How did your multi-verse get to this point?
And the response of Metro on here is I'm a passive observer.
I just watch everything from a macro scale.
And that's when he kind of picks up on the fact that the function of the
chronicler it's a simply observed, but what he wants to do,
it's actually fixed things right.
Is to fix them multi-verse and make it right the way that it's supposed to be.
So when he says yes, right. When, when the chronicler is more or less, like yes,
then at the end of the day, Medtronic is like, okay,
it's kind of difficult to explain, right.
But what are you basically establishes here is that Medtronic itself is part of
the new gods and the new gods represent absolute good versus absolute evil or
seemingly absolute good versus absolute evil.
The nature of these characters and the nature of this is almost kind of meta
textual that you have heroes who exist in this universe and within the
multi-verse itself. And the idea is that the heroes are effectively written by,
you know, DC writers represented by the overboard,
in such a way to where they will always find a way to overcome.
It's why every villain doesn't kill Superman.
It's why it doesn't kill Batman every single time they fight. Right.
It's why Superman hasn't died yet. I guess he kind of did, but he ended up back.
It's why the superheroes basically always win is because it's the [inaudible]
representing DC comics,
writers that engineer ways by which the heroes will always come out on top.
And that's why he says things like the Omni versus finite,
because while the omniverse does represent all things that currently exist,
then there were only so many things that we as human beings have created.
If you go through, when you say like, if you want a catalog,
a list of everything that every human being has created in so far as like a
story that exists out there, then sure. There'd be a lot.
Whether it be millions and millions and millions and millions of stories,
but they stop at a certain number, right? They don't go on forever.
We don't look around and say,
there are an infinite number of stories that we as human beings have created
with regards to things like spawn or like the Twilight zone or the outer limits
TV show or something like that.
There's only so many of these things that we've created over the years,
right over our existence.
Now that number will continue to grow the longer that humanity exists.
But at the moment, right now there's only a only a finite number there,
but the potential is a limitless.
The potential of what we as people can create is limitless.
And so the idea of what,
what Metron says here is that because of the fact that everything that exists
within the omniverse, so like Marvel colleagues, DC comics,
all that kind of stuff that all exists because of the fact that people created
it. And so even if DC were to just close up shop right now, right,
is really what Metro is saying.
Even if this multi-verse were to die and never be reborn, right?
So like DC finishes dark nights, metal and says, okay guys, the book is shut.
They fire everybody. And they say, we're no longer making comic books.
Then like the memories of everything that's happened here will continue to live
on, right?
The omniverse representing Scott Snyder and Jeff Johns and all of these people
who are, who are currently contributing to,
or have contributed to DC comics and are still alive. And even us as the reader,
we will all remember this. Even if we can never read a DC comic again,
after this, we'll all say like, Hey, remember that story with Superman.
That's how those things will live on. And so that's, that's kind of, uh, it's,
it's exceedingly meta textual here,
but the chronicler still doesn't quite grasp it.
And so the way this ends is that Medtronic has fun.
Then it's easier to show you than it is to tell you.
And so what he basically ends up doing is kind of blasting him with the full
totality of what it means to truly understand the codex Omni versa.
He basically gives him true knowledge, like a, like a,
it almost beyond multi-vessel and Omni Versal cosmic awareness.
Seemingly what he does is kind of introduce the chronicler to us,
basically tell us like about the real world,
that kind of seems to be what happens, whether or not that's actually the case.
I don't really know. Right. It's just, I'm just kind of suspecting here.
But with that being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
core. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop it.
No, we'll catch you all later. Please.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].